microphones here
good afternoon everyone and thank you
for joining us today
first I'd like to say that I want to
thank all of the emergency responders
who've been on the ground working around
the clock since the onset of this Trail
trained derailment protecting the
community and preventing any loss of
human life or energy injuries
I had the opportunity to thank many of
them earlier today these public servants
represent the best of us and I'm deeply
grateful for them and their incredible
service and dedication
I also want to thank our local state and
Congressional Partners who are here with
us today Senator Brown Congressman
Johnson and Congressman de Lucio as well
as many members of the delegation who
are on the ground working hard on this
issue Senator Vance Senator fed
fetterman Senator Casey Congressman Nels
congresswoman Sykes as well as Governor
Shapiro and governor dewine with whom I
spoke with yesterday
an emergency response effort like this
requires a whole of government approach
all levels of government working hand in
hand to keep residents safe I'm proud to
say that's exactly what's happening here
in East Palestine
nearly two weeks weeks ago the residents
of East Palestine experienced a terrible
terrible incident with the derailment of
train cars carrying hazardous substances
this incident has understandably shaken
this community to its core forcing
families to temporarily leave their
homes
worry about their health and safety of
their children and even question the
information that they're receiving from
all of us
the community has questions and they
deserve answers
I want the community to know that we
hear you we see you and that we will get
to the bottom of this
I've told residents including Miss
Christina Ferguson who's home whose home
I just left and had the privilege of
meeting with earlier today that I
understand her fears and I understand
her family's worries
I'm a father first and foremost a
husband and a son of parents over the
age of 70. All Families need to know
that they are safe All Families deserve
access to clean air and safe drinking
water
I want this community to know that they
don't have to manage this issue on their
own as President Biden told governor
dewine
anything the state needs we will be here
to help
as governor dewine and I discussed last
night we are going to get through this
as a team and at the same time we are
absolutely going to hold Norfolk
Southern accountable and I can promise
you that
from the very beginning EPA Personnel
have been on site supporting local and
state Partners as they've LED emergency
response efforts
we've had boots on the ground leading
robust air quality testing including the
advanced technological aspect plane and
a mobile analytical laboratory in and
around East Palestine
since the fire went out EPA air
monitoring has not detected any levels
of Health concern in the community that
are attributed to the to the trained
derailment
EPA has assisted with the screening of
more than 480 homes under the voluntary
screening program offered to residents
and no detections of vinyl chloride or
hydrogen chloride were identified and
we're continuing to make those
screenings available to any Resident
that wants to have their indoor air
tested
we're also continuing to conduct 24 7
air monitoring to ensure the health and
safety of all residents as it relates to
water EPA is supporting Ohio and the
local government in determining what
impacts The Spill has had on Surface and
groundwater and ensuring that the
derailment has not had an effect on
drinking water supplies
the state is also working with local
Health agencies and Public Water Systems
to get their drinking water from the
groundwork that get their drinking water
from groundwater sources the state is
currently awaiting those test results
for residents who rely on private
drinking water wells EPA has worked
together with Ohio EPA and local Health
agencies to develop a residential
re-entry plan to ensure that homeowners
can get their private Wells tested
until test results are received the Ohio
Department of Health has recommended
that residents use bottled water
EP has also continuing to collect
samples from surface water for our
laboratory analysis in support of Ohio
EPA our analysis includes a full Suite
of chemicals including Vinyl chloride
and we are sharing those results with
the Ohio EPA and the Ohio River Valley
Water Sanitation Commission
EPA has also issued a letter to Norfolk
Southern outlining actions at the site
and how the agency will hold the
railroad accountable for cleanup and
cost under epa's circular Authority
let me be clear EPA will exercise our
oversight and our enforcement Authority
under the law to be sure we are getting
the results that the community deserves
and in coordination with the state we
will be here as long as it takes to
ensure the health and safety of this
community we're going to get through
this together and we're not going
anywhere until we do with that I'll
invite Senator Brown up to the podium
Mr Reagan thank you Congress delusio
welcome and Congressman Sykes and my
longtime friend Bill Johnson thank you
and administrator thank you director of
the Ohio EPA and vocals thank you for
the work that and I've been very
impressed with how the two epas have
worked so well together I was with mayor
Conaway earlier today I spent an hour or
so with the only full-time
firefighter uh Chief Fire Chief drabic
and about a half dozen of his volunteer
fire departments there are about 40 of
them their fire department is right next
to maybe 30 feet 50 feet from the tracks
and the train did the train to derailed
two miles earlier uh sooner it could
have destroyed the whole fire station
and much else so and special thanks to
the mayor and the fire chiefs the work
they did save people's lives pure and
simple I want to thank Ann Vogel the
head of Ohio's EPA and the EPA employees
both the state employees the EPA and the
federal employees of the APA for coming
in here and spending every day in the
last two weeks I'm here today to listen
to people of East Palestine tell me what
they need from the Senate and from the
house and from the federal government
I've been working with the White House I
spoke to the new uh the new Chief of
Staff to President Biden just yesterday
about East Palestine it was literally
the top of his agenda and my agenda when
we spoke on five or six different issues
we heard today from Ms Ferguson as
director as administrator Regan said who
has had great difficulty coming back
into her home others have wanted to come
back in haven't been able to yet but we
have urged people about 500 so far have
been tested when they come back to their
homes and that's very important that
everybody should ask for that test
before they go back into their homes if
they've evacuated and we also expect and
so far they've done it on Norfolk
Southern to pay for every one of those
tests I also as I said spoke to the fire
department today 40 of them for
essentially 40 to 43 hours were full
time at the site of that fire after the
fire started Friday Friday night almost
two weeks ago my office and I are
exploring every option from the
beginning I talked to the National
Transportation safety board I talked to
the federal EPA talked to
um the the Centers for Disease Control
talk to the federal rail authority to
make sure they were coordinating and
doing what they needed to do we've sent
letters bipartisan letters Senator Vance
and I with Senators Casey and fetterman
from your state to both to the
administrator and to a couple other
agencies to make sure they're that they
are doing the right thing I in the end
the important thing to me is that we
hold as the administrator said that we
hold Norfolk Southern accountable
um that means accountable for the test
for people to move back in accountable
for all the cleanup that will take weeks
I don't know how long but at least weeks
to assure people that the water's safe
and the air is safe and the soil is safe
for their children for the 4 000 plus
residents here and make sure Norfolk
Southern uh does what it says it's going
to do what it promised one other point
to make I think is as Norfolk Southern
writes checks of a thousand and two
thousand dollars for residents I just
ask ask Norfolk Southern uh to not force
people so far we think they haven't done
that to force people to give up their
legal rights to accept that money there
is no there is no justification ever for
that these are people that are
struggling that some have lost their
jobs at least temporarily others have
lost a great deal because they're away
from home miss Ferguson today talk do we
ask her about her hotel bills and you
can't stay in hotel for a week without
spending a lot about pocket money and
that's just something that Norfolk
Southern needs to come so my my job will
be to keep listening to people in East
Palestine uh and Caleb in my office who
lives in Mingo Junction just one County
south of here will continue to monitor
he will be here regularly I will be here
as often as it takes and most
importantly I will be watching Norfolk
Southern watching them and letting them
know I'm watching them is important as
anything I can do so am I introducing
Congressman Johnson are you speaking
next I'm going to wait I'm sorry
Congressman Johnson next and then go
from there
well thank you Senator and thank you
administrator Regan I I want to Echo
just a a couple of things that have
already been said what a
what an unmitigated
disaster this has been inflicted on the
people of East Palestine no Community
should have to go through something like
this
but you need to know that you're not
alone
uh you've heard from
administrator Regan and I've heard him
say it numerous times
they're here
until the job is done for as long as it
takes and administrator Regan I want to
thank you
for coming today it means a lot to these
folks here
to director Vogel thank you uh to the
state EPA and for all the hard work if
there is a bright spot to be found in
all of this it's what Senator Brown
talked about the collaboration between
the federal EPA and the state EPA and
the work that they're doing to try
and solve the problems as they as they
are identified uh that has been that has
been a bright spot I too want to thank
Miss Ferguson for opening up her house
uh her home and sitting and sharing with
us the anguish and the fear uh the
frustration the concern uh long-term and
near-term for what this has meant to her
family and as she was talking I I sat
there thinking there are so many
families in this community that feel the
same way that she does and they just
don't have an opportunity to voice it
here's what I want to say to
the residents of East Palestine
You Are Not Alone
I am here I work for you it's not the
other way around you don't work for me
I work for you my office is open you've
heard administrator Regan say call the
EPA if you have problems with your air
testing if you need to get your house
tested director Vogel is working the
water side of the issue at with the
state EPA we can get you those resources
but if you've got other questions and
concerns that you're not getting
answered call my office I'm not that
hard to find you can find me on the web
www.billjohnson.house.gov
you get in touch with me there and I
guarantee you we'll get you an answer
now Senator Brown and I are going to be
working on some other things
once the national Transportation safety
board report comes out and we find out
what caused this thing we think that we
have good ideas about what caused it
there are a lot of questions about how
this could have potentially been
prevented
and what we can do to make sure that
that nothing like this ever happens to
another community
either here in Ohio uh or across the
river in Pennsylvania anywhere
this kind of thing should not happen
so uh thank you folks for coming out and
covering this today helping us to get
the message out to the residents of East
Palestine now let me turn it over to
director Vogel
afternoon I'm Ann
Governor dewine's director of the Ohio
EPA on behalf of Governor dewine I do
want to say to the residents of East
Palestine thank you so much for coming
out last night thank you for sharing
your concerns thank you for listening to
us explain science and test results and
the nerdy stuff we had a lot of good
conversations and as everyone has said
here please know that you're heard I've
got a whole team here Governor dewine's
cabinet officials are here I'm here on
behalf of Governor dewine we really
appreciate administrator Regan being
here with a lot of his team as well
administrator Regan has been talking all
day about taking down barriers to
Residents getting help and that is just
the right message that is consistent
with the conversation I know Governor
dewine had with uh we've got
administrator Regan but also President
Biden this morning so this morning the
governor did talk with President Biden
he has requested assistance from the CDC
he has requested assistance for in terms
of medical professionals on the ground
to provide physical and mental
Behavioral Health counseling services so
that request was formalized just a
little bit ago so please you can find
that in the news as well
I want to say thank you to the Ohio EPA
team who has been on the ground since
the accident they're doing a phenomenal
job they're keeping a close eye on the
railroad on the recovery efforts
remember that this is the emergency
phase we're getting the contaminated
soil and water off the ground and away
from you that is what's happening right
now
we are not going anywhere the
remediation phase is next and it will
take as long as it takes
so please
epa.ohio.gov we're posting all of the
sampling results that we get I have the
unenviable position of maybe updating
some news for you administrator Regan
that we do have the municipal will test
back
that probably happened while you were in
transit and the water we are not showing
any evidence of any contaminants the
governor pushed that news out yesterday
the municipal water wells are safe to
drink
so that is great news uh in terms of
those results we will continue to test
we will continue to test and be helpful
testing private Wells I've been having a
lot of good conversations with our
regional administrator for region five
of the US EPA we're talking about how to
partner we heard you last night
we heard that you are fearful and you
are concerned even if you're not within
the mile radius about your wells and
your air we're going to figure out how
to expand that region we want you to
feel comfortable being safe in your home
the sign on
uh that and introduces you or welcomes
you to East Palestine says East
Palestine it's the place to be
so our commitment to you from governor
dewine and the Ohio EPA is that we're
going to return it we're going to make
sure East Palestine continues to be the
place to be thank you very much thank
you for being here
administrator
what we'll do is I'll I'll answer yours
first and then we'll have Tim Carroll
and my team help facilitate the
questions
and local resident resident question
given the test results that so far are
showing no contamination
he was asking a view of the other
authorities who could allow your
children to drink the water would you
allow your children to pay in
you know what I would say is if those
homes have been tested and if those
homes have been tested by the state and
given a clean bill of health yes as a
father I trust the science I trust the
methodology that this state is using and
as a parent I would but if those homes
haven't tested or if they're on private
well water I would advise that they get
those homes tested and continue as
governor dewine in the State Health
Department has recommended continue to
use bottled water until those homes get
tested I would encourage every family in
this community to reach out to the state
or EPA to get their home air quality
tested and their water tested we have
the resources to do it we want to do it
and we want people to feel secure and
safe in their own homes
is being used represents the company
what would you say any Resident that has
any question about their air quality or
water quality please reach out to EPA
please reach out to the state we will
gladly test their air and test their
water
I tell them that we are we are looking
at well water we're looking at Municipal
Water we're looking at surface water
we're testing every aspect of the water
and every aspect of the air and we are
using very sound science and Advanced
Technologies to ensure that we're
protecting these communities surface
areas
different homes
if people touch them and then touch
their face is that something that they
should be
you know I think that's more of a
question for the state the state has
Primacy in terms of leading this
response and so I'll defer that to the
EPA director
testing is not currently being done in
terms of surface
to state of Ohio
stability I know that there are some
toxicologists who are doing it privately
I've heard about that
the we haven't found a significant we
haven't found residue where we've been
looking the nature of the controlled
release was such that those material is
combusted and dissipated into the air
but certainly it's an option for
homeowners to test the surfaces
and if folks could just list their name
and Outlet wouldn't ask questions sure
you know here's what I'd say the
Advanced Technologies that we we're
using to test the water and the air let
me speak to the air uh we're using high
technology uh that spans from an
airplane that we deployed over the
community to a mobile van we have
stationary air monitors and we've
personally tested uh over 500 or close
to 500 homes for their indoor air
quality we are testing for all volatile
organic chemicals we're testing for
everything we're testing for everything
that was on that train so we feel
comfortable that we are casting a net
wide enough to present a picture that
will protect the community
question for Senator Brown
um what um does the area need to do to
become eligible for federal assistance
well um I've been working with Governor
dewine uh Dan Vogel just talked to you
about his uh declaration this morning we
sent him a letter late yesterday he is
responding by either either well asking
though he talked to the White House this
morning and the White House has talked
to me about this uh I think all of the
whether it's FEMA whether it's CDC
whether it's EPA already whether it's
fra whether it's the surface
Transportation safety surface
Transportation safety board St all of
them are on board so you will see that
seamless work between governor dewine on
behalf of the state and President Biden
and me and I assume Senator Vance and
congressman and the two Congress people
here from Ohio today working on this so
I think there's nothing to worry about
that way
look like well we don't know it's what
governor dewine asks for but it's CDC
testing it's working on the the people
in charge of rail or fra in the surface
Transportation safety board I didn't get
that right but close enough
um on any any of those agencies that
Governor HHS has involved any of those
agencies that Governor dewine needs
service from
the state is eligible that the state
wants
I I don't think there is I think that
everything that the fed the state
government is
everything that I can see that state
government asks is asked for they are
eligible and I will fight on behalf of
governor dewine in the state to make
sure that they get those services
what can the federal government do to
change those regulations or like alert
people in the area when there are
happiness yeah as soon as we learned
about that my team in Washington uh
began working with the Department of
Transportation to understand how that
process works what is the criteria for
being labeled a hazardous
carrying or hazardous material carrying
train how does it happen who pulls the
trigger to say yes or no is it one car
out of a hundred is it 20 cars out of 50
we know that 20 of the 50 that derailed
here had chemicals in them it also has
something to do with the types of
chemicals that are in there there are
different levels of chemicals some are
more hazardous than others and it really
depends on some of that and so we we may
in fact need to make some changes to
determine uh to make sure that states
know it and that when States know it
then that they pass it down to
communities because that will determine
and some parameters about how that train
is operated too so the bottom line is is
that we're on it that's another reason
that's another reason why I think it's
really important that the transportation
secretary come here and take a look at
this himself
let me let me answer that for a second
too because because these are all
Interstate travel governed by the fra
and the NTSB uh the governor's right
about this
um both bill and I uh he said he didn't
really know it I didn't really know it
but those trained those those cars
however many of the 50 cars of The 100
cars carry these chemicals that car
should be labeled with those chemicals
we made it with that designation to mine
we're going to try to get fra or NTSB to
do it but we think we might need a
change in federal law and Bill and I
will work on that if that's the case
what was it
what if the train has been designated
well would it have to slow down
well it would have meant it would have
meant people monitoring it if the fire
fires the fire department would know
what it is immediately that would be
helpful
um I think that it would I it's not
clear to me that that engines always
follow the speed limits in different
parts of the country and it they they
probably drive faster in rural areas
than they do in urban areas those tracks
are not necessarily built for that speed
uh understand uh that that Norfolk
Southern they did major stock BuyBacks
major dividends in fact the the total
stock BuyBacks and dividends were
greater than the investment they made
and in rails they need to pay more
attention to upkeep of rails if they're
having those cars yeah suffice suffice
to say that when we get through that
analysis when we get the report back
when we figure out how that process
works uh obviously the more volatile the
more Danger address the hazardous
material on the train is it's going to
guide it's going to determine the kinds
of parameters that the train is operated
by so that's that's going to be a work
in progress but we'll we'll keep you
posted
you know what what I want to do is not
get ahead of the investigation that's
being led by the Department of
Transportation the the president has
indicated that we all should do what he
said from day one which is a whole of
government approach so you have multiple
federal agencies looking at this issue
and you actually have multiple levels of
government here today with Congress
local government state government and
the federal government so we're going to
do a full evaluation of what occurred
collectively and then we're going to
govern ourselves accordingly we're going
to look at every aspect that needs to be
tweaked so that we can be sure that
nothing like this ever happens again
Saturday
we have been at homes where they have
train cars in the backyard they had to
throw out the trampoline and the kids
toys and all that kind of stuff in the
backyard
two questions number one your family man
you have kids
absolutely
those trainers were on fire there was
that plume and also
um if you're looking to buy a home
there's a lot of people that are like
wanting to sell would you move in you
know I have to say listen this is uh the
site of a very serious incident these
are all valid questions people have been
unnerved they've been asked to leave
their homes uh this is a a site that is
uh we are responding to an emergency to
what I would say is the charge that we
have is ensuring that if people come
back to their homes that they're safe
and based on the air quality analysis
based on advanced technology and best
based on the work that the state has
done to test the water the air and the
water are safe for those residents that
we have deemed being safe and to come
back in if the water or the air has not
been tested I am asking the residents to
please seek out that testing from both
the EPA and the state of Ohio
if the EPA said it was okay if they came
to your house you would stay put
if the EPA uh
said that my air quality was safe and if
the state said that the water has been
tested and the water quality is safe
then I would trust those readings and if
I uh and yes I would re-enter my home
now obviously there are people who would
make different decisions based on their
means and if people want to go different
places and want more assurances or want
time to pass a little bit they have a
right to do that but for those who can't
I am asking that they trust the
government and that's hard we know that
there is a lack of trust which is why
the state and the federal government
have pledged to be very transparent as
soon as we get information we're posting
that information people can look at that
information they can also have third
parties look at that information and
verify it the state of Ohio and EPA are
working hand in hand and if we say that
the water is safe and the air is safe we
believe it because we've tested it and
the data shows it
he he samples are saying that the air
and water for the city or the Village of
East Palestine is safe but a lot of
people we've talked to are skeptical of
those all saying they have health
concerns now what do you want to say to
those residents you know for those who
are experiencing some sort of adverse
Health reaction we ask that they please
seek medical attention also we ask that
they can contact the local and State
Health agencies because we want that
information we want to hear from people
we also though have done the testing in
specific areas water and air and for
those areas that we have deemed safe we
believe that because the science and the
data proves that but that is not to
Discount any experience that any
Resident is having so if they're having
those experiences please see seek
medical help and please notify local
Health agencies
if one person said they were coughing up
blood and they've had a lot of issues
with breathing I mean does that not say
something with the results
you know it's it's saying that it's
saying that we should really encourage
those individuals that are having those
experiences to seek medical assistance
and be sure that the local Health
agencies have that information as well
they should reach out reach out to the
local Health departments the local
Health departments the State Health
departments the county health
departments
last night we had we had representatives
of the County Health Department there
there was one of the doctors there and
if you remember a question similar to
this came up go to the doctor
get a finding on what the ailment is get
that medical record keep that medical
record make sure the county health
official knows about it make sure that
the authorities like the EPA and others
they need that information if there's
something happening that the tests are
not are not detecting now we're not
saying that that's the case but if it
were we would we would want to know that
so
that keep yeah
prevent it
like the administrator said every family
has to make their own decisions but the
science speaks for itself if you're if
your home has been air tested your water
has been tested if you're still having
other symptoms then you have other
decisions that you need to make and you
need to let the authorities know if you
don't have a physician start with the
health department and uh and let's go
from there if you don't have any answers
call my office and we'll try to help
individual cases figure out what to do I
just
want to just run all of the agencies
agencies
we have just a couple more minutes just
one more question
um I'm Alex Anthony from
the food found in the Ohio river and if
that's where
orange I need water supplies in other
areas
I do
so the orsenko which is the Ohio River
sanitary folks there the ones that their
early detection system the organic
detection system has been tracking what
you're talking about the plume we know
where it is it'll be in Huntington West
Virginia tomorrow so far the levels of
detection are so far beneath any health
concerns as established by the uh the
federal agency that determines Health
levels for new toxins so we don't have
any health concerns we also are
confident that the water treatment
systems all along the Ohio River are
following it very closely and so far the
existing treatments in place are capable
of handling any level of contaminants
that we've seen
right now that someone might show up in
five ten years is there a plan to like
continue monitoring this area there is
part of the again so there's two phases
to an incident such as this this is the
emergency phase we are as we speak
working on the long-term remediation
plan that will include a sampling plan
for surface water for drinking water for
air all of the things that you're
talking about and for soil as well
thing if you if you have you been able
to talk to people who say they were ill
and determine if that in fact there's no
connection to the drilling and here
you're talking about testing water soil
so far coming forward but I think she's
asking about the monitoring individuals
right and I don't have an answer for you
I'm not the health department but as I
think we mentioned there are other
Representatives here from the governor's
cabinet and the local Health Department
did address that last night as well the
governor of course calling in the CDC to
set up some of that physical health
testing I think is meant to address
those concerns